oh this is not going to end well they
both understood the assignment
it's just like boom I know
they're just disgusting I don't know
what to tell you
hello I'm Dr Ann Jones the ABC's nature
nerd and today we're going to be looking
at extraordinary animal relationships
from mind-blowing teamwork to amazing
parental love this is too much from
tactical group living to animals that
seem to adore us they're humans I love
you
foreign
five standout relationships of the
animal kingdom
[Music]
humans often look to Penguins as if
their relationship Gods like they make
for life and they have really high
fidelity rates but is any of that
actually true
foreign
[Music]
so I think these ones are King Penguins
and they're incredible I can't even look
at them they're supremely adapted to
getting around underwater and a penguin
will spend like 75 of its life or
something like that in and under the
water Penguins do almost everything in
groups they like to nest in sort of big
groups that they call rookeries or
colonies they like to hunt in groups
they generally just like to hang out in
groups
is that one nibbling the camera
so they're much more comfortable there
than they are on land
it's actually more energy efficient when
they can to do the tobogganing on their
tummy rather than walking because their
little feet are so ungainly uh-oh they
get split oh no
oh no
run run you can make it go mate oh he's
going he's going he's going oh yes
[Music]
it's funny because they're probably all
going to the water right but the
instinct is for safety in numbers his
Instinct its instinct is to be with its
friends so one of the strategies they
have for still being able to go to the
supermarket and come back and feed their
babies is lumping all of their kids
together into a creation so yeah that's
adorable
look at those little pink Tooties
did he just Nick someone's Rock
foreign
[Music]
twos are Nest Builders and they will use
vegetation to make their nests but this
is somewhere where there is no
vegetation it's only Pebbles what they
want to do is create a nice sort of Bowl
shape so if it snows it means that
there'll be really good drainage so the
egg doesn't sit in a pool of water in
that muddy sort of stuff so in the
battle to win a female's heart he'll be
looking for the perfect Pebbles
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
the pressure is so intense to have the
perfect rocks that you just might turn
to a life of crime
oh no there's an unfortunate teenager in
the background that's got like a mullet
going on halfway through a malt
everyone
please look away
it's about to get Randy so they're doing
a courting dance he's moving into
position she's moving the tail to the
side the cloaca will become visible in
five
four three two
yeah
[Music]
and done so yeah penguin love do they
mate for life most Penguins do not mate
for life there are some that have long
lasting relationships and there are
others that have long lasting
relationships and have lots of sex on
the side and there are others still that
just get a new man every single year
yeah I mean if the penguin wants to get
out there and you know experiment
who way to get in the way so whether
they're monogamous I would say
in some cases but not all so Southern
rockhopper penguins are an interesting
case they sort of seem to meet for Life
they'll come back as the same pair again
and again and again so what's the secret
to their success well they spend very
little time together it's like 20 days a
year if that and the rest of the time
they spend very far apart they
essentially go to opposite corners of
the globe and that's the secret to a
good relationship
[Music]
even if these birds aren't the Hopeless
lifelong Romantics that you thought they
were you've got to give them some credit
for being some of the best parents in
the world and on top of that they
survive by being in just vast numbers in
extremely harsh environments
[Music]
we see dogs as loyal and loving
companions but how do they see us can
they feel love and empathy in a human
sense or do they just see us as one of
the pack
[Music]
I love you
oh my goodness so cute I love you
it sounds like the dog is trying to say
I love you but they can't really create
sounds the same way that we do as human
not with the same accuracy I love you
but it is trying to copy some sort of
sound or at least make a sound on this
command because it wants a reward and
that's what it's going to get praise Pat
snuggles treats it could get any or all
of the above I love it
it might be slagging her off it might be
saying you know what Joanne that dress
doesn't look good on you
[Music]
dogs have incredible senses of smell
they've got 300 million or so olfactory
sensors in their nose we've only got six
million or something poultry like that
they can even smell cancer cells within
a living human body and I spoke with a
woman named Karina whose dog saved her
life by sniffing out cancer
[Music]
hi I'm Karina Kirk Dre and this is my
wonderful little doggie Bella boy just
started lying on my chest and licking
then she started lying after a couple of
weeks I'm crying then she started
bouncing on my and I felt around and I
felt a lump so I went to the hospital
and it was cancer unfortunately and I do
believe that this is why Bella was
getting more and more determined over
the months because it had spreads and I
wasn't listening to her and I didn't
realize what she was saying she was born
in my she was telling me that I was
cancer and it was dangerous so it
happened on my chemo it was a hard graft
but I've done that they've said that
Cancer's gone but I've now actually give
me the word remission yet I don't think
the will give me that word until I
finish my 10 years of treatment please
please please if you've got a cat a dog
whatever and they start acting out of
character please listen to them I
wouldn't be alive with that little one
here Karina is a lucky woman but she's
also a smart one right because she was
taking notice of what her dog was trying
to tell her and in the end it saved her
life
oh
[Music]
that is very adorable it makes it look
like a puppet
they're human teeth you know very small
little dog dogs actually do have a sense
of humor it's just more likely to be
like in a game of keepings off or like
sort of tug of war and that sort of
thing
because what are you doing
oh big stick oh no
ah
tragedy come on let's go like this
[Music]
hey
good boy you did it dogs have been
domesticated over the course of like 30
000 years right and over the course of
that time we've basically bred them to
be stupid dogs have been able to give up
some of their problem-solving abilities
because we look after them so dang well
it turns out that this is actually
scientifically proven wolves are able to
work in teams more effectively and
they're also able to problem solve with
more efficacy than domestic dogs do
we all have them so much we have
accidentally made them Goofy
[Music]
what did you do
[Music]
ah there's so many videos like this on
the internet where you see the dog like
hiding behind the couch looking guilty
we're not actually sure that they can
feel guilt
[Applause]
there is a certain amount of primary
emotions happiness sadness that dogs can
feel akin to the human emotions but the
stuff that gets more complicated than
that we're not really sure what the dog
is reacting to is all of the cues subtle
or otherwise that you are giving off so
when you walk in and the places like
covered in ripped up toilet paper and
you're like what the duck happened here
the dog is like
oh no she's angry right it's having a
reaction to your action it doesn't
necessarily feel guilt
oh
dogs are probably the ultimate human
companions they want to please us they
seek us out for comfort and they improve
our lives in a multitude of ways so do
we deserve dogs
probably not to be honest but they
deserve to get the very best out of us
[Music]
you've probably never given much thought
to the little ants that are scouring
around in your back Garden but when it
comes to teamwork and strong family
tires these invertebrates are a force to
be reckoned with
oh no
oh that gives me the heavy duties
foreign
this is a death spiral
something's gone wrong
[Music]
looks like
Universe spinning
so how ants find their way through a
landscape is by following each other's
pheromone trails and what's happened is
there's been a break in the trail
someone's lost it and started going
around in circles following its own
trail around in circles and then the
next one does and the next one does and
the next one does and then before you
know it you've got an out death spiral
going on a lot of them probably will die
of exhaustion they just literally walk
around and around in circles until they
carve it
[Music]
oh God
okay okay snake bats ants
oh another strike
oh yeah oh God the bat is still alive
it's us I think what's happened from the
ants perspective is this Unholy ball of
hell has fallen from the sky onto their
territory and Disturbed probably the
entrance or something disturbs their
nest
I reckon that the ants gave off an
emergency pheromone emergency emergency
we're under attack and that's why there
was this like swarm of ants coming out
to defend yeah it's like which circle of
hell is that
it's all up see the snake gets so
agitated by all of the ants biting that
it lets go
I actually manages to fly away
what a beast
makes me want to get into the gym most
ants can lift around 50 times their body
weight which is huge right I mean if it
was me that would be like the equivalent
of three cars or something so like move
over strongman ants are in town
oh
oh my God it looks like the cartoons so
these ants are working together to carry
it really effectively I mean I thought
that only happened in the cartoons look
at it they have literally raided the
picnic
researchers have found in the common
American field ant that the neck joint
where the head goes onto the thorax can
actually withstand 5 000 times its own
body weight it's a huge amount of
pressure being you know right on that
tiny little bit that joins the head to
the thorax these guys are just
incredible and one of the reasons they
can withstand it is because of their
exoskeleton right so they don't wear
their bones on the inside they wear
their bones on the outside as a sheet of
armor that goes over their whole body
and that means that they're really
durable it means also that they don't
have to use muscle strength to stand up
like we do they stand up by themselves
because of their exoskeleton
foreign
[Music]
floods bring out all sorts of things and
that looks like an ant raft uh maybe a
fire ants they're known to Raft ants
that live in swampy conditions have this
ability and it's creepy as hell look at
him oh it's making my hair stand up on
end oh oh well look they've created like
a floating highway system so fire ants
have this ability to form these huge
rafts and the rafts can include their
whole colony and what they're doing is
linking together in sort of like Little
T Junctions they've got lots of
different connection points with the
ants around them and they've got hairs
on their body which trap air bubbles
right little oxygen bubbles that's what
one of the things that gives them the
sort of ability to float and it also
means that the ants even the ants at the
bottom won't drown they will actually
survive under there for a really long
time and because there's like literally
tens of thousands of ants it forms this
really big mess so cool
ants are insanely collaborative
creatures I mean they rely on safety in
numbers and they're each able to make a
decision that benefits the whole Colony
they truly know that Teamwork Makes the
Dream Work
[Music]
see us live in some of the harshest
environments on Earth so does that mean
that they come together and work and
live as a team
or do they prefer to stick it out alone
foreign
[Music]
he got octopussy the seal does not want
you making that sort of sound he was
having a nap it's been several times in
my life where I've wanted to Wallop a
dude in the face with an octopus so I'm
on the seal side but actually this may
have been an accident because octopus is
a really difficult thing to eat they've
got lots of suckers and they suck onto
you as you try and eat them so you want
to break it apart so it's trying to
Wallop it on the surface of the ocean
just smash it around and flail and it's
it's actually pretty gruesome they're
essentially trying to rip that octopus
apart just using the force of impact
on that guy's head
[Music]
Shins
I don't think he's happy oh
this is not gonna end well yeah
nah she's gone she's like I'm not having
any part of this
she just did the equivalent of climbing
out the toilet window
so elephant seals are called elephant
seals for that reason the big chunky bit
that the males have and males exert
dominance over a section of the beach
he'll have a harem you know of like all
of these females that he will mate with
in this one area he protects it like
super aggressively against other males
and in fact when there is a male in
charge of an area they actually call
them Beach Masters these guys weigh like
3 000 kilograms and the fights are
insane like it puts sumo wrestling to
shame
why got the proboscis
it sounds like someone doing a wet fart
through a PVC pipe you know
we're just going to sneak up
[Music]
he's trying to be sneaky
so I think that what's happening there
is the pup is trying to get a sneaky
drink of milk from a seal that is not
its mother because what happens is the
female seals will actually go out and
hunt and they'll only come back to the
colony to feed their pup for like two
days after that
like being a seal mother you know they
work really hard to make sure that their
pups are nourished so they're not very
charitable with other pups even though
that one is particularly cute the seal
pups just have to make do and exist on
their fat in between these feeding times
doesn't mean they don't try it on with
other mothers though and apparently
sometimes if a mother is in a deep
enough sleep you can sneak up and get a
little bit of a suckling
oh
[Music]
oh it's super dog's like looking away
don't be aggressive oh my God What's it
gonna do to me so I think that the seal
is a young one and it's used to its
mother protecting it in all situations
it's probably you know its first trip
maybe away from its mum and so basically
it's seen the dog and God are you Mum
are you my mother or thinks that it's
you know safety and numbers something
like that it's just like going to
something that it thinks it might
recognize
and they do call them dogs of the sea
right I don't think that seals are very
social with other animals outside their
own species so I think that this is
probably some confusion and what's more
the dog is extremely uncomfortable and
that poses a danger to the seal
and there's this thing right called seal
finger where you basically get a
bacterial infection
from a seal and it can happen from
people who are skinning seals and are in
touch with seal meat and things like
that but it can also happen if they bite
you you need to stay away and your pets
need to stay away from wild animals
I think that these ones are sea lions
because they've got like little Eerie
bits these sea lions are after a school
of sardines the idea is is they herd
them together into a dense Bowl where
all the fish are really close together
and then one sea lion will burst through
the ball at speed with its mouth open
and catches many of the fish as it
possibly can it's a really effective way
of getting a good mouthful not all seals
hunt cooperatively but there are some
that do and it's pretty spectacular
seals have these incredible whiskers
that they use to actually help them hunt
they're called vibrousy and it basically
means that they can detect movement in
the water right because they're really
stiff so when a seal wants to detect
what's happening it's got like low
visibility something like that it makes
its whiskers stand erect and it can
literally feel the swirls in the water
that a fish might make as it moves their
whiskers are so sensitive that they can
literally feel a fish breathing well not
breathing but you know the water coming
through their gills I wish I had some
actually seals are cheeky and
unpredictable
but whether they preferred to spend time
alone or in groups their lifestyles are
entirely built around their ability to
live in the harshest places on Earth
[Music]
referred to as the king of the jungle
and that's weird because they often
don't live in jungles and on top of that
if you look really closely you might
find it's the lionesses
that are really the bosses of the pride
oh
my gosh
they're in a safari park I think
I know
there's lots of lock the door oh you
could not accelerate quick enough could
you oh my gosh I didn't know they could
do that
lions
us that habitually live in big groups
called Prides there's multiple types of
intelligence right but but lions are
socially intelligent they can watch a
lion undertake an activity and just by
watching learn what to do themselves
they might even try and open your door I
know
so it's best to keep your doors locked
yeah sure I hope so
it's the female lions that do the
majority of the hunting and they go for
smaller prey like warthogs and smaller
antelope
Lions can run fast they can go at like
80 kilometers an hour but only over a
really short distance because they
overheat
getting closer
War hog is completely oblivious
that shows teamwork
oh my God look at how many there are
what were those birds there's too much
going on
he's such a poetic leap from that
wildebeest it's like barishnikov at the
prime
this is amazing that jump
and it almost looks like it managed to
get like a boot in on the way past as
well
bloody Incredible One lion will clock
the prey say a wildebeest and it looks
directly at the wildebeest and all the
other lions are like
ah a wildebeest and that is the moment
that the hunt begins because the Lions
don't really like to run they like to be
efficient and in this case efficiency is
teamwork he's looking
nervous oh
dear
oh
the females are not happy
terrifying sound
[Music]
the Lion's Roar is the loudest of the
big cats roars
foreign
has been very brave and decided that
he'll come up to a group of like six or
seven females who have got Cubs and be
like how you doing ladies they have none
of it none of it
and they've got good reason to do that
because female lions are induced
ovulators so what happens if a male
comes in takes over a big group of
lionesses he'll go around and kill all
the Cubs right and that forces the
females to ovulate and they have a whole
new batch of Cups the thing is though
female lions will defend their cubs to
the death
yeah you're in trouble oh stay away from
the water
[Music]
oh my God the little fluffy tail oh it's
just too much
[Laughter]
so cute
back at the water's edge
ah she got a good grip body of that time
oh God the other ones are at the water
on the other side
why would you be a mother if a male
Coalition Takes Over The Pride the
females will all have babies around the
same time right so they've got like a
heap of cubs so it's easy to sort of put
them into a big group so that some
females can go off Hunting and some
females are in charge of looking after
the Cubs get away from the water they
truly are the supermums of the animal
world
oh
[Music]
the relationships that Lions have are
incredible they coordinate to hunt they
call on each other for help they work
together to raise their cubs I mean
they've got it all could you get a
better team player
I don't know
these five extraordinary animals have
incredible social lives
the way that they form and strengthen
bonds with each other is nothing short
of amazing
strong and enduring relationships mean
that these animals not only survive in
their environments they get to thrive as
well
if you like this video and you want to
find out more amazing animal facts then
you should find my podcast It's weekly
and it's called what the duck yes you
can find it on the ABC listen app and
also anywhere that you find your
podcasts